y
todo está yendo bien esas son las
palabras que oksana sigue repitiendo día
tras día intentando mantener alto el
ánimo en sus pacientes es la jefa de las
enfermeras de un hospital psiquiátrico
en el suburbio occidental de kiev llora
por la madrugada en mi habitación para
que ninguno de mis pacientes o colegas
me vean y si toma algunos sedantes
entonces si estoy calmada desde la
mañana la mitad del personal no regreso
al trabajo desde el inicio de la guerra
y muchos pacientes no tienen ningún
lugar a donde ir siguen jugando ajedrez
y coloreando para matar el tiempo el
director del hospital está haciendo todo
lo posible para mantener una rutina
incluso mientras los misiles siguen
cayendo en las noches
la mayoría de los bombardeos ocurren en
la noche cuando empiezan a disparar no
dormimos ante la noche las explosiones
sonaban muy fuerte podrían ser las más
fuertes que tuvimos hasta ahora
hay un búnker en el sótano una sobra de
la época soviética hoy los pacientes se
van a dormir medio vestidos para poder
saltar de la cama y llegar al refugio el
personal corto el acceso a internet e
intenta proteger los pacientes de la
realidad de la guerra que se libra
afuera